Karen Pascal et Thomas Christopher
travaille pour le mv-o ils sont comme
tous les membres du centre de
volcanologie les seuls sur Montserrat
autorisés à se rendre sur la zone
interdite pour leur travaux de recherche
[Musique]
pour soit prendre des données
supplémentaires soit pour réparer des
stations des stations sismiques des
stations GPS c'est toujours dangereux le
volcan est toujours actif donc c'est
pour ça qu'en fait on y va avec la radio
comme ça si jamais il se passe quelque
chose ils vont pouvoir nous dire de
partir rapidement
[Musique]
tu habitais là non
plus haut tu habitais à Plymouth non
papy mousse à côté plus proche du volcan
là c'est l'école où j'allais tu vois les
bâtiments derrière les arbres ben
c'était mon épaule
c'est le bureau du proviseur le bâtiment
principal
les différentes salles de classe le bloc
a je me souviens il y avait aussi le
pressing la boulangerie
le magasin de bricolage et ici c'était
le supermarché
à 4 km en contrebas du dôme encore
fumant du volcan
Plymouth rebaptisé aujourd'hui la Pompéi
de la Caraïbe n'est plus qu'une terre
grise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors en clap ou pas enclave
je ne suis pas sûr
tu vois il y a une concentration de sel
là-dedans ça c'est une enclave les bases
sont saturés en silice
ça ça vient du dôme oui
[Musique]
comme sur l'autre versant du Sud-Est les
coulées pyroclastiques ont creusé un
sillon une vallée par laquelle si une
autre explosion se produit la fureur du
volcan dévalera
[Musique]
ça reste une zone d'exclusion parce que
on est juste au pied du volcan donc il y
a du potentiel pour que le dôme par
exemple un moment s'effondre qu'il y ait
une explosion quoi que ce soit et ça
peut venir dans cette direction